it's time for the launching conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour for show you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon genes good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this evening mister
william bradford huie noted author and
analyst and editor-in-chief of the lawn
gene Cronus cope and Colonel elson
Talbert and editor of the New York
Herald Tribune our distinguished guest
for this evening is mr. miles jay lane
united states attorney mr. Lane your
course are now one of the most famous
crime fighters in the United States
since your office's panel the his case
the Frank Costello case the Remington
case the Rosenberg case so I'm sure that
our viewers would like you to tell us
something about these cases tonight sir
now first of all the Rosenberg case
where this man and his wife were facing
electrocution just what is the crime for
which the Rosenbergs were convicted well
they were convicted for conspiring to
violate violate the Espionage laws of
the United States in that they had
inspired to among other things to turn
over the secrets of the atom bomb to the
Soviet Union and both this man and his
wife are now facing electrocution unless
the President and seed is that correct
sir that's correct now I'm wondering if
the Rosenbergs are given the government
any help since their conviction or given
any indication that they would like to
help the government in uncovering other
Soviet spies to this moment the
Rosenbergs have not cooperated at all
they've given us no information and
they've been very adamant
as far as cooperation is concerned when
they save their lives if they talk well
let me say this i think that the
American government is quite reasonable
and if they were to cooperate to the
fullest extent I'm quite sure that that
would be taken into consideration with
respect to what what might happen to
them in the future well now with with
all of your experience with them and in
the trial sir do you have in it there is
as to why they they have refused to give
the government any information at all
well I'm certain from what I've seen of
them that they are dyed in wool
communists and that they are they are
completely devoted to the Soviet Union
and to them it's more or less of a cause
and they probably believed that their
modest to a cause or something of that
effect now do you think that it's that
it's terribly important that our
government forced them to talk or else
execute them well you put that question
rather an odd way I think it's very
important to this government that we
take a farm attitude not only towards
the Rosenbergs but towards anybody that
conspires in any way to to overthrow
this country or to commit acts of
espionage against it you think that
perhaps it might have some effect on
future cases if you if these people do
not talk on how much information you we
might get out of future cases well I
think it will have a direct bearing upon
future cases if we don't take a very
firm attitude now could you illustrate
for our viewers are just how extensive
was their knowledge about some of our
secret activities during the course of
the trial there was testimony that the
Rosenbergs had information respecting
such things as our fire control system
atomic energy for airplanes they also
had some knowledge of this rocket that
was in contemplation one time called the
sky platform which was a huge rocket
which was to be spitting senator space
and he'll there and at through a system
of electronics it could come down and
destroy a city they also had information
as was developed at the trial respecting
our fire control and our underwater
detection of submarines then it isn't
true sir that they were very small fish
a great many Americans I'm sure
wondering if they weren't
inconsequential people that it from your
experience that is not true they were
relatively high up in the apparatus well
I don't know just how high up they were
but i think that the Rosenbergs were
very important in the apparatus so one
of the apparatuses well now you've
you've just secured the conviction of
william remington i believe for a crime
somewhat similar to the crime of Alger
Hiss is not correct mr. Lane aah both
hiss and Remington were convicted for
perjury and one of the counts upon which
Remington was convicted was for having
given over secret of classified
information to a
representative the Communist Party who
was also a Soviet courier hiss was
convicted for perjury and denying that
he had ever given over any information
or classified as secret information from
the State Department to I believe was
whittaker chambers so in both instances
although they were both Remington and
hiss were convicted for perjury it was
perjury for lying in effect when they're
asked whether or not they had given over
any classified information to others
outside of the government department
well there was no doubt about the fact
that both of these men were members of
this apparatus which you've just
described it is there no well I wouldn't
say that they certainly knew people who
are communists but whether or not they
actually members of the Communist Party
is difficult to say Remington of course
was also convicted for having lie when
he said that he had no knowledge of the
young Communist League at Dartmouth and
in the course of the trial we developed
that he had many contacts with
communists and intended communist party
meetings and so forth well incidentally
that young Communist League at Dartmouth
sir and ejected a rather human note in
the trial I believe you're an alumnus of
Dartmouth aren't you well I happen to be
the president of the general alumni at
Dartmouth and naturally with so many
Dartmouth men being needled and ribbed a
little bit respecting the fact that they
were timing is Saddam pyth in the late
30s I was most anxious that Remington be
convicted not only because I felt he was
guilty but also because of the fact that
I was adopted and as the prosecutor of
remington i don't think it hurt the
college too much to have a top with man
put remington away well what you say
that you had the full support of the
dartmouth alumni and this matter i would
say without fear of contradiction that i
had the one
sent support of every type of alumnus in
existence well sir I'm sure that I
viewers would expect to hear from you
the latest report on the Costello case
what's Costello doing now while Costello
was convicted as you know for contempt
of the Senate and he is now in Milan
prison yesterday we started an action
against him in connection with a lien on
his income taxes for roughly four
hundred eighty thousand dollars and we
also have a the naturalization case
against him in the office which should
come on for hearing a trial and the not
too distant to chew well in all of this
very interesting experience that you've
had sir the one that's in the news most
tonight is the waterfront situation in
New York now can you give our viewers
outside of New York some indication of
how extensive graft is on the waterfront
well we have had as you know there are
several of there's a state crime
commission working here on the
waterfront and doing an excellent job
and I have had a grand jury working for
the past ten months and that has done a
magnificent job also in the course of
their deliberations and probings we have
found extensive evidence of other
evidence of extensive corruption and and
exacts and all that sort of thing and
does this corruption affect every
American family in some way would you
say in view of the fact that New York is
the greatest port in the world and the
Comets of New York way out distances
that of any other I would say that the
corruption and the kickbacks and all
that sort of thing in New York City
affects the life of every single
American and I think it is a particular
interest every housewife in America
because the graft and the kickbacks will
affect the price of every commodity
that's being used by every family in the
States mr. Lane you prosecuted
successfully gangsters communists and
racketeers I'm wondering what you think
is the nation's greatest minutes well if
I were to pick out any one thing as the
greatest menace of this nation faces it
is the complacency of a lot of our
citizens I mean I think the American
public is sufficiently intelligent from
the most intelligent public in the world
and I have all the confidence in the
world in it however I think that we've
got to realize that it's time for us to
accept the responsibilities as citizens
by that I mean this that we should have
more people interested in doing jury
duty and also taken an interest in
parent teachers clubs and taking the
very intense interest in the future of
the younger people of the country well
as a final question mr. Lane a great
deal has been written and said about the
part that labor unions may have had to
do with the waterfront scandals now are
you going do you expect to get the
cooperation of of the American
Federation of Labor in the
investigations oh I think the American
Federation is shown that it's with us
one hundred percent I don't think that
labor itself is at fault a bit I think
labor in labor they have a few
unscrupulous leaders and but management
also has a few in its right now I have
every confidence in labor I'm sure the
American League the American Federation
label will do everything it can to
cleanse itself of the wrong elements
well thank you sir for being with us
this evening thank you the opinions that
you've heard our speakers expressed
tonight have been entirely their own the
editorial board for this edition of the
lawn gene prana scope was mister william
bradford huie and Colonel else'll
talbert our distinguished guest was mr.
miles jay lane united states attorney
you